today we are going to see how AI
research is changing the landscape of
gaming video conferencing Robotics and
so much more dear fellow Scholars this
is two minute papers with Dr car now
first here we talk about papers this is
not a paper so you will see results that
we cannot evaluate as thoroughly as we
normally do with peer-reviewed research
however I still think it is important to
talk about because even though this is
not a paper but it is the papers coming
to life in the world around us you see
these Technologies appeared or will
appear in products that millions of
fellow Scholars are going to use all
around the world so I would like to show
them to you and I will note that we have
no business ties with Nvidia now here
they talked about hybrid AI where your
local graphics card will do one part of
the computation and a different part
will be streamed from the cloud so why
well for instance noise removal for your
video conferencing should run locally on
your machine as it requires low latency
it cannot wait for the cloud to do all
this it would take too long there is not
enough time for that but photoshop's
generative fill can take a little longer
in the cloud to ensure it runs on a
smarter AI model and give you your text
to image results here now these are the
local and Cloud models but what is this
hybrid thing well consider their
previous work on creating virtual
characters with generative AI earlier
they showcased a system which can
automatically come up with dialogue for
a virtual character in a video game
first the text that the character needs
to say will be synthesized by an AI then
a text to voice AI will make it actually
say it in a human voice and the mouth
movements will also be synthesized look
hey Jen how are you unfortunately not so
good how come I'm worried about the
crime around here it's gotten bad lately
it sounded a little stiff could have
been a bit more natural but this is only
the first version of something that was
previously nearly impossible so here's
the breakdown when you talk to a virtual
character your local voice input is
transcribed locally this then goes into
a large language model in the cloud and
when we get the text response from the
game character speech is synthesized in
the cloud and then it comes back to your
machine where the lip syncing is done
quickly and locally and all this happens
without you noticing all this Wizardry
that is quite impressive and this is
available for developers to use right
now we can also use generative AI to
create these virtual characters
themselves too like the video game
characters from this earlier video they
can all be given an identity and a
backstory and like good little actors
they will pretend to be this person they
can even become a fellow scholar now at
this point my reaction was that I'd love
to see that in action in this framework
and luckily that's exactly what happened
Nova you ever get that uncanny feeling
we're like those AI constructs from the
old sci-fi flicks but now we're too
quirky now these characters are much
more true to life and it gets better
every time you enter the room the
conversation will be different all
synthesized on the fly if the occasion
calls for it words are connected to
actions as well and you might get a
drink for free also more games will come
with RTX technology with AI based Ray
tracing super sampling anti-aliasing you
name it all in the name of better visual
quality for Virtual Worlds these look
fantastic and during March Ray tracing
is also coming to Diablo 4 and RTX remix
will help you remaster previous games
and add retracing effects to it and
upscale old and blocky textures if you
ask me anything that can make the portal
game better is good news in my book and
also hold on to your crowbars fellow
Scholars and check out this glorious
halflife 2
remix their new textto image AI is also
out this can perform not only the usual
image from text prompt but we can also
add these masks to apply the prompt to
only a subset of the image extend the
image and more note that these tools
also Exist Elsewhere and that this is a
paid service and before you pay free and
open source techniques for instance
stable diffusion also exist and if you
watch Twitch where you can watch a
stream of someone playing games the
quality of these streams can be enhanced
with RTX cards oh yes cards a new series
of graphics cards the Super Series was
also announced I love these animations
in which they introduce them this one
looks like it is coming straight from
outer space this has more Cuda cores and
more memory for faster generative AI new
RTX laptops are also coming if you can
always look up independent benchmarks
for the particular application you
intend to use them for before buying now
now we already know that AI is infusing
these robots in more and more warehouses
and factories but now they are also
permeating agriculture construction
health care and Retail as well due to
GPT these robots Now understand our
commands significantly better and don't
forget a virtual version of these
factories can be modeled by a generative
AI which is kind of mind-blowing and now
these robots can train in these virtual
environments to make sure they are safe
before being deployed in the real world
and in a simulation we can also do tons
and tons of domain randomization apply
changes to these virtual world to make
sure these AIS are safe and work
properly in any kind of situation this
used to take professional artists and
days and days of work now it runs in a
matter of minutes and just tax CRS are
needed and now we can tell them to shake
hands lie down and not their heads this
will lead to smarter vacuum cleaners and
lawnmowing robots and so much more what
a time to be alive when I was a PhD
student my experiments created lots of
data for my deep learning projects but I
was not looking for more data I was
looking for insights this is what
weights and biases does and it is the
best
everyone is using it try it out now at
wb. me/ papers or click the link in the
description below